Ukraine has dismissed Russia's calls for
a 36-hour ceasefire as a ploy President
Putin has told his troops to observe a
truce which has come into effect this
morning and it's to Mark Orthodox
Christmas but Kiev says that it won't be
following saying that Russia will only
get a ceasefire when it leaves Ukrainian
territory
now the Russians want to use Christmas
as a cover to stop the advance of our
guys in the donbass for a while and to
bring in equipment ammunition and
mobilize people closer to our positions
what will it result in just another
increase in their losses
well our International correspondent
Alex Rossi joins us live he's in fastiv
which is southwest of Kiev Alex good to
see you this afternoon
um any evidence of even a one-sided
ceasefire
well certainly from Russia's uh position
they are saying that they will maintain
a unilateral ceasefire this was ordered
by Vladimir Putin yesterday telling his
defense minister Sergey shoigu to hand
down the order to troops along the line
of contact but we are hearing reports
that there is shelling going on along as
hundreds of miles of trenches where the
fighting is taking place there were also
Air Raid Sirens going off where we were
we're in Kiev when it came into effect
at 12 o'clock so a few hours ago we
heard the air raid sirens we didn't hear
any sounds of explosions and none had
been reported but those Air Raid Sirens
we understand were sounding around the
country as you can imagine there is
profound suspicion here of Russia's
motives if anything at the moment
Ukraine has the momentum it has the
initiative and they see this really as
just a ploy by the Russians to buy them
time so that they can reinforce their
troops in positions where they are
facing a fairly desperate situation it's
a chance to strengthen their logistic
lines bring ammunition up to the front
so although it's been rejected by the
ukrainians they haven't said that they
they will or they won't fire him which I
suppose is indicative of the fact as a
part of a military strategy why would
you signal to the enemy uh what you are
or are not going to do but one would
expect that it will carry on one other
word though it's very very cold anyway
and because of the festivities you would
expect the tempo of the fighting perhaps
to calm down in many places as a result
of that but certainly the ukrainians
profoundly suspicious and that they have
rejected what Vladimir Putin has offered
as this ceasefire ostensibly for
Orthodox Christmas and they say the only
truce that Russia is ever going to get
is if it withdraws completely from
Ukrainian territory